[Música]
el empresario colombiano álex saab ha
llegado al gobierno del presidente
nicolás maduro compareció este lunes
ante un juez federal del tribunal del
distrito de eeuu para el estado de la
florida en su primera audiencia tras su
extradición de cabo verde saab se
presentó de manera virtual a esta
audiencia inicial en la que se le
imputaron los cargos de lavado de
activos y sobre evaluación de contratos
el juez del caso negó la libertad bajo
fianza a saab y acordó una próxima
audiencia el próximo primero de
noviembre tras su extradición el
gobierno de maduro decidió retirarse de
la mesa de diálogo con la oposición que
se llevaba a cabo en la ciudad de mexico
para ello quiero entonces saludar a
nuestra primera invitada del día ya ese
mayor petit politólogo e investigadora
del crimen organizado transnacional
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo americana en france 24 muy buen
día para ti porque el caso saab es tan
clave dentro de la política venezolana y
porque tras su extradición a eeuu el
oficialismo se retiró de la mesa de
diálogo que ocurría en mexico con la
oposición
bueno alexa ha sido el responsable de
varias operaciones que ha hecho el
sistema que opera dentro del marco del
estado venezolano ellos han manejado a
través de la figura de álex a una serie
de negocios turbios que están
relacionados con irán con china con
rusia y con turquía por tanto la
información que posee esa y que puede
llegar a manos de los fiscales federales
es una de las grandes preocupaciones que
tiene en estos momentos el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y de sus aliados es
importante destacar que el caso de álex
está acá en los eeuu está relacionado
única y exclusivamente con el lavado de
activos por más de 350 millones de
dólares relacionados con unos contratos
para la construcción de viviendas para
pobres en venezuela y adicionalmente a
ello es lo que se conoció como un
negocio con las divisas de bajo precio
que el estado venezolano ofreció
de control de cambio y que alexa y sus
aliados habrían utilizado para hacer
negocios falsos con contratos y recibos
de suministros completamente ficticios
eso es más importante para que el
régimen de maduro se preocupe ya que en
estos momentos no solamente está el tema
de alexa sino que hay una investigación
abierta sobre miles de millones de
dólares que fueron lavados a través de
los bancos norteamericanos y del sistema
financiero o la moneda impulsó los eeuu
y ahora my board le quiero preguntar que
ya sabe dijo que no iba a declarar no en
contra del gobierno de nicolás maduro
pero es posible que él pueda cambiar de
opinión en su próxima audiencia que será
el primero de noviembre es que tanto
puede cambiar de opinión sabía hablar y
testificar en contra del gobierno de
maduro que finalmente es lo que busca
eeuu con esta tradición no
bueno es importante aclarar que la
próxima cita de esa en la corte está
relacionada con lo que se conoce como la
segunda audiencia para que el acusado se
declara culpable o no culpable tenemos
entendido y de acuerdo a lo que ya se ha
recabado él va a declararse no culpable
lo cual lo lleva a un proceso bastante
largo en el cual lo tanto la fiscalía
como la defensa junto al juez deben
escoger un proceso para la selección de
jurados y supuestamente él va a ir a un
juicio él tiene hasta antes de que se
inicia el juicio la posibilidad de
cambiar de decisión y declararse
culpable o en otra categoría pues
empezar a colaborar con la justicia
hasta el momento tenemos entendido que
desde cabo verde y ahora que está en el
estado de la florida él ha decidido no
colaborar con la justicia sin embargo
tiene la opción de declararse culpable y
no colaborar con los fiscales
no puede tenerlo hasta que se inicie el
juicio muchas personas que consideran
que no están acusadas con cargos
evidenciales deciden hacerlo a última
hora porque hay que recordar que cuando
la gente va a juicio a quien no he
estado instruir en la sentencia es más
ceder ahora my work como llega saab al
ser tan allegado no al gobierno del
presidente nicolás maduro tengo
entendido que tenía una relación
estrecha con la senadora colombiana
piedad córdoba y ella a su vez con el
gobierno del entonces presidente hugo
chávez y luego por supuesto con el
gobierno del presidente nicolás maduro
que va en esa misma rama política no
entonces fue por ella el eslabón que
llevó a saab al gobierno de maduro
todo parece indicar que sí pero él
también tenía una línea de acción con
otros personajes que estaban muy
cercanos al expresidente juan manuel
santos y pues de allí uno empezó a
conocer el nombre de alexa justamente
cuando se hacen convenios y acuerdos en
colombia con el gobierno para entonces
de hugo chávez y de ahí en adelante se
inicia toda una carrera como contratista
del estado venezolano que le permitió al
ex a convertirse en uno de los hombres
más ricos que estaban ligados al régimen
venezolano también tiene relación con el
caso del oro venezolano tiene
acusaciones en su contra debido a esto
no
en estos momentos la acusación que está
en curso en los eeuu de manera oficial
tiene que ver con contratos relacionados
con la construcción de casas para pobres
en venezuela y con el contrabando
prácticamente de alimentos puesto que
los contratos fueron considerados falsos
de acuerdo a la acusación de la fiscalía
del distrito sur de nueva york pero le
puedo decir que existen otras
investigaciones abiertas donde aparece
alexa y su socio álvaro pulido que
tienen que ver más con el tráfico de oro
de esmeraldas y de otras otras preciosas
así como también convenios hechos con la
república islámica de irán por petróleo
y otros
instrumentos que hasta el momento se
desconoce pero que están bajo
investigación ahora hay también un país
es claro nadie sea clave antigua y
barbuda saab tenía pasaporte diplomático
de esta isla se presume que por ahí
podría también pasar el oro que se
extraía de venezuela que es a usted
mayor sobre esto
bueno hemos leído la investigación que
está bajo en estos momentos ellos pero
que llegó por informantes y allí
definitivamente no sólo él tenía un
pasaporte que le facilitaba todo el
proceso porque hay que recordar que en
el caso de estas islas los ciudadanos
pues tienen muchísimo más derechos que
cualquier otro que sea colombiano o
venezolano y en este sentido sabemos que
existe una línea de tráfico o rutas por
parte de esas pequeñas islas caribeñas
para llegar a otros lugares de europa
puede ser mayor gracias por su tiempo
por analizar por hacernos entender un
poco más en este caso de alexa por qué
es tan importante en la política
venezolana gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo american
france24
un placer siempre un gran saludo a la
audiencia